did you know that YouTube is one of the
best platforms that you could be growing
your personal brand on right now yes
there's other social media but I am all
about YouTube and so in today's episode
of the YouTube Made Simple show we are
going to be jumping into Channel review
so if you're joining me live feel free
to drop your channel and we will get
right into today's session my name is
Heather Torres and I'm the host of the
YouTube Made Simple show and I am so
excited because I get to be joined by
none other than Rob from vid IQ vidiq is
one of our partners here at think media
and Rob is their star um how would I say
it Creator on the channel hey Rob how
you doing today I like to call myself
long suffering I need a break uh creator
of vid IQ but you know each of everyone
hey everybody how y'all doing I want to
do some shout outs to the sobriety
Playbook two as one uh the unplanning
digital media Jessica and Darwin all
joining us live thank you welcome how
you all doing yes it's my favorite to
have people that are joining us live I
think it's so fun when we get to do
different Channel reviews and Rob you're
you're no uh you're this is this is easy
for you right you you're streaming over
on the vid IQ Channel how many times a
week now every day seven days a week 24
hours a day it feels like I kind of joke
of a joke like this I always check the
week number so that I know but it's
episode 42 of live streams this week
this year but then I've been doing this
now for five years I've been working at
vid IQ for five years and I've been
Lively streaming every single week
pretty much from that first week so I'm
up to episode I don't know probably
about because you do it twice a week 500
and blank so I've done it a lot of times
but even then Heather like every channel
I open up I get that moment of fear like
how am I going to be able to offer
anything of value to this Creator but
something usually ends up spewing out of
my mouth which I think creators take uh
with some value and are able to apply
yeah and I think it's really fun we get
to do these type of reviews we do them
here we do them over on the vid IQ
Channel and my favorite thing about that
is that we get to help creators you know
that's really why we're here we want to
help you on your Journey on YouTube and
not only do we have the opportunity to
help you here live but we also have a
really exciting uh event happening here
at think media which is our tube 1K
challenge so if you're trying to figure
out how to get to your first 1000
subscribers and Beyond earn your first
one thousand dollars and grow your
impact using YouTube I'll tell you more
about that as we get more into today's
stream but Rob let's jump into we have
so many people that have submitted
Channel reviews already and I want to
let you know uh fam how do you actually
do this so this is what Bloom films just
asked how do I request a review uh you
can say that you would like a review and
then our team's actually grabbing those
links and Rob and I have a document on
the other side that allows us to be able
to grab the link to your YouTube channel
and Hope hopefully give you a review now
we do get a lot of submissions when it
comes to YouTube so I want to make sure
that you know that we'll get to as many
as we can here live but what I really
suggest is that you get out a notebook a
piece of paper a pencil and be taking
notes on some of the things that Rob and
I are sharing on today's Stream So
Outlaw you just say I would like a
review and then our team is trying to
grab those as quickly as we can and we
did post around the interweb so if you
are part of our video ranking Academy
group if you saw this posted over on
either of our channels our team is
grabbing them from all over the place uh
so you can hopefully get a review today
we'll also tell you about a really
exciting partnership that we have with
vidiq later and so many things happening
in today's live stream Rob let's jump
into the first review yeah so uh the
first channel I picked from the list is
a gaming channel I I don't often tend to
do these on our live streams because we
have a resident gaming expert done but I
thought I'd tackle this one you know
just a
freshen freshen my feelings about gaming
channels and I'm really encouraged by
this one which has already had a bit of
success you know the the problem that
all gaming channels have is that there
are a lot of gaming channels so it's a
very saturated Market but this channel
has two and a half thousand subscribers
which is a great start for a gaming
channel and as I look at some of the
recent videos what I'm Curry encouraged
to see is a through line and this is
something that all creators can benefit
from not just gaming channels and their
through line from these particular
videos in particular are
let's take an old nostalgic game and see
if it's still fun to play today in 2022
and so what that allows the Creator to
do is not be
um stuck with one game and they're
playing that endlessly constantly trying
to feed that particular audience for
that particular game it allows them to
go on many different Journeys with that
same through line of is this older game
more enjoyable to play today and as we
can see from the views they're fairly
encouraging you know for a Channel with
two and a half thousand subscribers if
you're getting three and a half thousand
views 1500 views one down here with 10
000 views nearly those are all good
signs I guess my question is
why did you start this mini series of
content and then stopped two months ago
for me I would have been making a list
of at least 50 to 20 video games that I
want to try and make videos on and be
doing one a week if possible
because they all seem to be starting to
bring in an audience the other thing I
might think about is are there any
particular games that are perhaps more
popular than these I'm seeing Guild Wars
2 Eve online and puff Exile I've never
heard of that last game I must admit are
there any old Mario games or
things that are still probably quite
popular that you can maybe tap into in
terms of an audience and then maybe one
last thing in terms of the thumbnails
most of them feel like loading screens
or artwork from the games themselves
with that simple line hooked I'm
wondering if you could maybe address a
question as to why this game may still
be very popular in 2022 for example Eve
online is there still a big Community
around that game which means that it's
still a very popular to play or in Guild
Wars 2 for example is there a
combat system which is unrivaled by
anything in 2022 it's still as enjoyable
to play then as it as it is now so try
to think of more wise to get the the
viewer more intrigued and curious about
each of these games but in terms of a
gaming channel Heather the fact that
they have this unique through line of
figuring out whether stuff is still
enjoyable today that's a Fresh Approach
and I really think this gaming channel
has the potential to grow if they commit
to a certain level of consistency one
video a week on this topic I love that I
love that and if you're a gaming channel
take notes about exactly what Rob just
said um because there's still room for
gaming channels to explode on YouTube
right Rob
there is there is you've got to find the
that little pocket of uh content Niche
style theme that hasn't been done to
death like if you just come onto YouTube
with a let's play attitude of gaming you
know PewDiePie popularizes that over a
decade ago and people are still doing
that and we often see channels that have
been doing let's play content for six
months and they're still getting under
10 views and it's clear that what
they're doing in terms of a traditional
format isn't working so these fresh
approaches are really signs of
green shoots in The Gaming Community
even though there are so many people out
there right now yes so so amazing well
hey we're going to jump into the next
review I want to shout out a few people
that are here we've got uh the Creator
classroom VR VRA fam in the house we've
got everything Aja uh VRA fam in the
house that is our video ranking Academy
um part of our uh way that we help
content creators here at think media so
I want to welcome you guys to today's
stream thank you so much for being there
and that's right sobriety uh playbooks
got it right you gotta hit that like
button if you like streams like this uh
and if you would like a review just let
us know I would like a review just like
the Royal Mars Brothers and fam I've got
three lined up from the live stream
right now Rob I know you've got a couple
in the background but let's jump into
this one because I'm excited about Bloom
films I think we've reviewed uh Bloom
films
um maybe before but Bloom films is
already at 23
000 subscribers so congratulations on
getting to that number already I clicked
over here on the about page just to see
what you're about and this uh the
Creator said my name is Michael bloom
and I film stuff
that's great Michael
um I would love a little bit more uh so
what else could you add to this
um who are you creating content for what
type of films are you creating uh you
can look at your about page really like
a business card like this is your
elevator pitch of why someone would want
to be a part of your community uh then
came over here on community Tab and want
to say hey um you posted a month ago
Bloom films you have 23 000 subscribers
I want to see you posting over here on
your community tab a little bit more you
got the happy New Years and you've got
the um when was the last time you
interacted with the community posts so
uh love to see more of that action
happening over here one thing that I
love about YouTube in general is that
you have an entire ecosystem at your
fingertips you know a lot of people
think I need to be on Instagram I need
to be on Tick Tock I need to be on
LinkedIn I need to be all over the place
but did you know you could do stories
here on YouTube you can do uh shorts
like almost like reels or tick tocks
here on YouTube you can interact with
your community here on YouTube you can
go live here on YouTube so you have an
entire ecosystem and I'd like to see you
lean more into that bloom films um as
you go looks like you're doing a mixture
of the short form and the long form
content and if you did it here YouTube
announced that they are going to be
paying creators for short form content
Rob I'm excited about that as a content
creator to get paid to make content uh
we can talk a little bit more about that
in just a little bit but
um this is exciting news as a content
creator to know that you can be making
money from your short form content uh
and even more money than say tick tock
you know Tick Tock has an entire fund
and then content creators split that
fund here on YouTube you get paid for
the content that you create uh so I
think that's really exciting if I'm
looking at the channel itself I want to
see like what uh success leaves Clues
and really I definitely see that you are
an entertaining style channel uh based
on the content that you're creating
um I I it's not that that can't happen I
think that that's a really great place
to be but when I'm looking at the
different views that you have
um I want to know how you can be going
deeper into
maybe a certain type of content I see
you're doing you know I lost a hundred
thousand dollars on the Mr Beast
challenge so it's pretty cool that
you're already integrated in with other
people that are winning on YouTube
um but I really want to see
um I think maybe more tailored content
to your exact audience so uh I I'm
looking at your content right now your
thumbnails are great you definitely have
that YouTuber Vibe
um but it's now trying to figure out
what makes you different Michael why
should someone watch you why should
someone subscribe to you what should
they be doing uh why would you be
different than someone else on the
channel um great job on consistency I
definitely see that you're posting uh
you know three shorts in the last three
days uh this one uh did really well 31
000 in one day which is really great
and this is her controversial opinion
really good title uh because it makes me
want to click on it to figure out what
the opinion is so if I'm looking at this
I'm thinking great Channel great start
to the channel but where do you want it
all to go have you reverse engineered
where you want all this to go
um when people say I want to be like Mr
Beast there's no one else like Mr Beast
there's no one else that's as crazy
um at the level that Mr Beast is at so
how can you be Michael on YouTube how
can you go deeper into the audience you
want to serve on YouTube and have you
written that down have you written out
who your ideal audience is have you
written out who you really want to be
watching um these videos and just
checking out some of your stats here
um eight videos posted in the last 30
days great job this is just the plug-in
I'm using from vid IQ and 45
000 views so right now Michael you are
on the way up and it looks like the way
that you're making money
um just from checking out your channel a
little bit is from YouTube itself that's
probably where you're you're headed with
the views and subscribers
um but I would want you to think about
your business model wrapped around
YouTube so
um anything to add to that Rob after
looking at this channel
you did raise a fantastic point about
the about section uh have a there are
changes coming to how your channel page
may look on desktop there's been some
teasing images I tried to find one but I
couldn't find one but if you go to
mobile I'm just going to show this on
screen now if you want to maybe just
zoom in onto my screen if my camera
Zooms in can you see that whenever
somebody visits your Channel
on a mobile phone
it shows the first I'd say a hundred
characters of your about section so that
is your value proposition you want to
give viewers another reason why they
should watch your content or subscribe
so try to remember as Heather pointed
out that the about section does have
more value than what you probably think
and then just go back to the channel in
general uh Heather I I saw I wouldn't
say lack of consistency but it seemed to
be sketchy like I can see in the top row
of videos I've done like three shots in
the last three days then there was a
break of a week then there was a couple
more shorts then a break of two weeks
and then a month and in terms of trying
to be consistent we would probably want
to see a Cadence especially with shorts
like several a week one a day that type
of
um Cadence and then maybe one long form
piece of content because it's clear that
viewers are coming to watch your content
I would be fascinated to know what the
average view per viewer is I'm
suspecting it might be quite High you
know if it's about if it's two or above
then that's suggesting that your viewers
are happy with the content that you're
making but they want you to make more
that they have an appetite for your
content but maybe you're not providing
enough
yeah and when I'm leaving looking at the
length of videos being posted um you
know this one was one minute 44 seconds
so it counts as a long form video but
that's pretty short I mean that's a
pretty short video three minutes two
minutes two minutes three minutes so
even the idea of you know why are you
creating content on YouTube and one of
the values that YouTube offers us versus
other platforms is the long form content
that's how you grow that know like and
Trust factor with your audience and so
being able to create content that's
gonna allow for a longer view duration
is really great right the longer average
view duration the longer time that
someone's spending on your videos
um with shorter videos that's just
shorter you get three minutes or if you
made a 15 minute video that's even
better if someone watches five minutes
through or ten minutes through that
actually helps you
um in the long run so just be thinking
about maybe making some longer form
videos too
um and I think that could definitely
help you out and uh someone asked Robert
now I think I'd love lost it but someone
said wait there's a change to creators
getting paid
for Here We Go Crystal asked wait did
they change the rules on making money
for shorts
they did Rob yes well they're going to
so I'm going to yeah as of right now
it's the same model as what Heather
explained in that as Tick Tock in that
YouTube have a shorts fund and you earn
maybe five to ten bucks maybe it's a
hundred uh for hundreds of thousands if
not millions of shorts views but that's
as the same problem with Tick Tock it
was a a fixed fund and the more people
who created the more that money had to
be diluted from 2023 onwards it's going
to follow more of a traditional ad
Revenue format that long form content is
on YouTube we don't know what the cpms
are gonna be or like what your average
earnings will be my guess and this is a
very very broad guesses it you're
probably gonna be earning
five dollars per one million views
because if the requirement is 10 million
views over 90 days that would suggest
about 50 to 100 of Revenue and you've
got to earn over a hundred dollars in
Revenue to have a payout from YouTube
um so that's my rough guess but yes the
the devil is in the detail the
requirements there are quite demanding
10 million shorts views in 90 days
for me personally I think four thousand
hours is a much more achievable goal and
I think the 10 million views may be
wrapped up in the music label agreements
that YouTube have made but the fact is
it's now easy to get monetized because
there is a new way to get money size
through shorts
and I think there are a lot more income
revenue streams coming to shorts in
terms of super thanks which I think is
going to be available to creators before
that requirement there's this kind of
light version of you two call it fan
funding whereby the requirements are
going to be lower and you have access to
Super thanks super chats memberships but
not ad Revenue so it gets very
complicated very quickly but yes
opportunities are coming and I think the
opportunities are only going to get a
lot greater 12 months down the line if
you're a shorts Creator but as for ad
Revenue specific quickly I'm still not
convinced on that aspect of being able
you've been able to turn into a business
but in the same token you should
probably never think of AD Revenue as a
business making opportunity on YouTube
is a lot more uh Revenue ad revenue
streams it can go down yes definitely
and just to highlight just you know a
lot of people are like well I like
making shorts I like making short form
content
um I just shared this uh in a talk I did
in California this week I just wanted to
show you how cool this was Rob
um this is Erica kohlberg and a lot of
people know her now because she has
definitely gone viral on YouTube
um she's viral on Tick Tock uh and she
really just started in 2019 and what's
crazy is that um Erica shared a video
I'm going to get to the video real quick
Erica shared a video that said how many
uh how much each of the social media
platforms paid her now she's got
um over like a hundred and let me get to
the amount of view she's got here she's
got uh on Tick Tock alone
452 2 million views that's a lot of
views right and this is how much each of
the platforms paid her and so just to
give you some idea of short form content
versus long-form content and why Rob and
I are definitely fans of the long form
content is you just have a better
Financial opportunity
um now you shouldn't not make shorts but
just to give you an idea of the amount
of income you can have from making
long-form content and of all of her
platforms she is the least amount of
following on YouTube yet YouTube played
her exponentially more for her views
because of that so I thought that was
pretty cool wanted to share that with
you guys
um about what uh what can really happen
on YouTube all right rob you ready for
your next uh review yeah let's do it
okay
this next Channel then I just want to
ask all of the viewers right now
what's this Channel about
and you can answer that within five
seconds like this is a channel that
doesn't have to make you think about the
content you know like instinctively
whether or not you're in the right place
and for those who are in the right place
they're gonna say yes this channel was
made for me Chris Alex uh just over 4
000 subscribers and the imagery from the
channel banner and the thumbnails it
just literally jumps out of the screen
slaps you in the face and says click on
me
fantastic work and we can see that um
right now at the beginning of October
this is
the Channel's boom period like if you're
going to be doing makeup for Halloween
this is the channel that you want to be
following and the timing is right there
about two weeks away from Halloween so
that that is a keyword is probably going
to start to Trend and this Creator is
showing you
the Fantastical uh things you can turn
yourself into like turn shoes into
monster feet with this easy trick and no
text it's all visually done so again in
terms of interpretation I still remember
this Heather from a video that Nolan did
on think media
um the average time to compute a visual
image is like 1.8 milliseconds it's like
it's instant and so as often as you can
use imagery to sell the Curiosity of
your thumbnails so these are all
fantastic they're experimenting with
both shorts and long form content I
wouldn't be surprised if one of these
shorts does go viral especially if
you're tying in popular characters such
as Voldemort magic UV makeup I saw that
you did some stranger things back when
that was released a few months ago
fantastic maybe you want to revisit some
of them if people are thinking of uh
Halloween costumes yeah that's probably
what the Creator should do if you
haven't already done this do a bit of
market research on one of the most
popular Halloween costumes this year in
2022 and make content based on those
choices uh that the average public is
searching for
but yeah I think the thumbnails are
fantastic I honestly don't know what
else I could uh add to this other than
your posting schedule
it's about
they did quite a lot of videos two weeks
ago but they haven't done anything for
seven days and I think it oh like
it's the middle of October this is when
you go all in yeah did you schedule did
you spend all of August and September
um batching all of his content together
I appreciate it probably takes a lot of
time to make this content given the the
skills and craftsmanship of this Creator
um but you know maybe that's a lesson
learned for next year or maybe that's
something that you can start to think
about for the Christmas period
Thanksgiving that type of stuff but yeah
ever incredible Channel fantastic
thumbnails
just more content more more as much as
you can
yeah I I'm I'm so impressed by this
channel I actually just sent it to my
daughter because I'm like this is so
cool uh she's really into
um the makeup and and all of these
things and you know if if this is one of
those channels too Rob where this is you
have to create something in order to
make a video right but not really you
actually don't have to just create
something I think channels like this or
any channel that needs to be in a
creative mode right like maybe it's
cooking maybe it's DIY stuff whatever
that is where you actually have to
create something another style of video
you can do is a reaction to someone
else's content so I would be looking up
all of the Halloween
um style content and I would want your
take on the way that they do it and so
that is another way that you could be
creating content without having to
create something to make that content
come to life
um I was was also thinking too I didn't
know Rob I didn't click through but are
they uh doing affiliate marketing based
on the different content pieces that
they're creating that's so cool let's go
through here yes okay good so we've got
some links happening which is really
great because people like me who buy
stuff online all the time uh I want to
know for sure
um what I should actually be buying
based on what you're doing and this is
also like you could if you've already
created content you could do like top 10
uh X Y and Z and you just put your
videos together to make one long video
people like to watch that kind of stuff
too so just know that there's a lot of
ways you can be very creative when you
are already creating something to be
able to maximize that type of content
over and over and over so
um this is so cool I could watch this
all day yeah I just wanted to I want to
select the video run in the background
Heather just to see if the quality of
the thumbnails transitioned into the
content and it clearly is you can see
even though I've got it muted the the
editing that's going into this the
pattern interrupts the lighting you saw
some a b-roll at the beginning then it
goes back to the Creator the lighting on
her could be a little better that's the
one tiny criticism there but overall
fantastic absolutely fantastic yeah yeah
really really cool wow and you're right
that thumbnail just so visual like this
white one into this cool one and that
color contrast we talk about that a lot
when we're doing reviews is you want to
have a contrasting color so the fact
that she shows shows purple behind the
bright orange is a really really wise
choice of color
um on the color wheel which makes sense
if they're an artist she understands
colors uh very well as we can tell so I
guess one other potential concern might
be uh What uh SEO are you trying to
Target here is how to make an easy
monster glove
something specific that people are
searching for or like how could you
um how to make a Halloween hand propped
I'm just wondering if easy monster glove
is the best way to have a broadest
search reach for this content but I need
to do more research on that to find out
definitely well
um we are going to jump into our next
review but I wanted to let you know
about something really awesome that's
happening here at think media so check
this out from Sean Cannell this video is
brought to you by
tube1kchallenge.com join the free five
day YouTube challenge and learn how to
turn on an endless stream of YouTube
views and then turn those views into
money join now by going to
tube1kchallenge.com or clicking the link
in the description
yes so we are starting that challenge
next week so let me know if you've
already signed up for it if you're going
to be a part of it and we're going to be
having some incredible giveaways and one
of those giveaways Rob is actually going
to be from vid IQ that's really excited
um about sharing we'll share a little
bit more about vid IQ and a special
promotion that we have with them
um after our next two reviews but let's
jump into the next one which I'm really
excited uh to review because I love
minimalist channels I am probably not a
minimalist but I love watching
minimalist channels and uh coming right
over here right away to modestly minimal
um going into that description again I
really want to see this description
level up a little bit here on the
modestly minimal Channel my goal is to
bring you honest reviews on items that
are actually worth spending your money
on
um this is definitely from my
perspective a a men's Channel as well so
that is even one more detail that you
could be adding into the description of
the this video but what I love is that
already this Creator Rob with 800
subscribers is jumping into one of the
styles of video that we talk about which
is review specific products and a lot of
times people are like well I don't
really have products in my Niche you do
have products in your Niche and even in
something like this uh this content
creator is reviewing a jacket I think
it's really cool that this content
creator goes all
um takes you on a journey when he's
doing these types of things you can see
here it says included includes a paid
promotion so it's not just about the
jacket he's going out he's gonna take
you on a journey he's telling a story
how would you use it really really great
um this also looks like uh simple
videography this is a tripod just set up
really cool he's going into details
about the jacket which I think is great
and here's another thing he went down
and he's like user friendly I wear
unboxing and then he's got some pants
and so really interesting to see that
it's not just about minimalist life but
this content creator is really doing a
great job of capturing an audience with
the exact thing that they're looking for
and how do I know that because he has
800 subscribers yet his review specific
product videos are doing great this one
right here has 1.4 K views these boots
have 2.1 K views
um so it's really interesting to see
that these types of videos are doing a
great job
um
I would also say too that we could work
on some of the titles uh because I
here's the thing is someone typing in
wmp eyewear unboxing I don't know maybe
that brand is large enough that that
actually is exactly what someone's
looking for
um but I would actually I don't know
for me personally that feels very very
very specific unless this is actually a
company that has some volume happening
in it that someone would want
um to search for that so
um great job on that and yeah I love
that you're reviewing different products
and it looks like it's very much like
menswear simple things but then also we
have a Tesla so this is where people
start to just decide to make whatever
videos they want I know this is four
months ago
um but to me this
yes it can be
um minimalist lifestyle but it's a car
so it feels like a little skewed on the
audience that you may be pulling in
because just because you drive a Tesla
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
interested in this style of content so
just looking through a couple things
that you're doing here um checking on
your stats uh I think it's really great
that you are in the green on all of your
things and 20 videos published now I
know that short form videos and long
form videos but it's definitely helping
you with your views overall so really
great job on this one and I would also
say The Branding
um is really great you're doing a great
job with The Branding keeping it very
minimal as you are in the minimal
lifestyle and I would just say that this
is one of those channels also that you
should be
uh studying your competition because if
someone's into the minimalist lifestyle
there's a lot of different content
creators that are doing this and I would
figure out what are the winning topics
that you could be talking about Beyond
just reviewing specific products inside
of this lifestyle that's my quick review
of this channel Rob
anything to add
uh there's one thumbnail there just
makes me chuckle just because I'm I'm
reading it not as intended it's the one
that says uh I think he says never buy
pants again but I'm reading it as
leather pants by again yeah that one I
don't know why I just go top to bottom
and then right and then top to bottom
the question I would maybe ask the
Creator is just given the brief
video that um we saw it felt like it was
very much a storytelling going on a
journey like I'm not just going to
review this jacket you know how many
buttons does it have is it comfortable
to wear I'm actually going to go on a
journey with the viewer which felt
fantastic and the editing was of a very
high standard and it looked as if that
Creator spent at least an entire day
going out filming on location and so on
and so forth
maybe the title is letting down the
video like it's very functional you know
it's a flint and Tinder 365 pants from
this company this is my review but I
feel as if you could be
telling the viewer a little bit more in
terms of creating curiosity about these
I don't know what that is specifically
but maybe think about how these pants
make you feel like you kind of intimate
that the other the best pants that
you're ever going to buy you're never
going to have to wear another pair how
can you turn that into something that's
curious in the title because I think
content-wise it's fantastic and it's one
of those classic cases if you look at a
channel it's thumbnails it's content and
you think this channel should be doing
more views or it should have more
subscribers and it doesn't and I'm
wondering why that is and I'm wondering
if maybe the the title pitch is
something where they could be better
they're very functional they seem the
same SEO based search base and I think
this Creator can do more than that um
especially from the rest of the content
uh that the titles seem to be something
that are going in One Direction where
the the rest of the branding is going in
another Direction definitely
well great
um thank you rob for that part of the
review uh what is your next Channel Rob
and then we'll get into a special deal
we have with that IQ yeah so I love the
channel name here uh reluctant diy-ers I
would certainly be one of them and the
channel has over a thousand subscribers
they are staying a traditional uh
education how to based area of YouTube
but by having that simple title uh
channel name reluctant DIY as you are
defining your target audience
and again I would like to see that
emphasized more
in perhaps your thumbnails and titles
you are doing it to a certain extent for
example here repair drywall hole drywall
repair for beginners you've got some
holes there
I wouldn't be pointing at a text I'd
maybe try incorporate you just failing a
DIY all of the time to try and represent
the viewer like I just I've just made
this hole in this wall and now I need to
fix it or how do I need to avoid this
again in 2022 I feel as if you're only
going to get to a certain stage as a
content creator if you're trying to
appeal to search all of the time and my
guess is
if I sort by most popular you have a
number of videos that have over 10 000
views which is fantastic but those are
kind of one-offs you'll you'll start to
rank in search people will discover this
content but perhaps they're not coming
back for more of your content so a key
metric here would be return viewers are
you converting new viewers into return
viewers and just judging on your
thumbnails and titles I'm not sure that
you're doing that to a certain extent
and again it's the same it's like with
think media and vid IQ we are
essentially at Heart YouTube education
channels but why do people keep coming
back to our content it's because I think
from vid iq's point of view there's a
somewhat lightheartedness there's a bit
of entertainment and comedy I think for
uh think media it's a kind of you're
getting the whole dossier like if you
open up one one page of the think media
folders like this is fantastic I'm going
to turn the page and here's another
fantastic thing another fantastic thing
and so I'm wondering if you're going
from drywall for repair for beginners to
electrical outlets uh to uh solo stove
review is there a through line there and
I'm not 100 sure but given given I've
said all of that
fundamentally I think the thumbnails are
going in the right direction you tend to
be using these solid backgrounds cutting
yourself out maybe having one or two
items of DIY on there
feel it is a bit text Heavy my challenge
to you would be if you're gonna write a
if you're going to create a thumbnail
with eight words such as this one well I
want to try and challenge you to halve a
number of words you're using in that
thumbnail because in terms of
deciphering the contents I'm going to go
back to this channel Chris Alex where
you can decipher this Con content
instinctively for reluctant DIYs and
maybe spending an extra second or two
and that is so crucial when you're
stopping somebody's um swiping and then
trying to convince them to click
um
really great review Rob that was I mean
I was like trying to think of something
else to say and Rob just gave a great
review that was really really good well
there you go I haven't used a community
tab for three weeks so what should they
do Heather yes Community tab you gotta
use that Community tab that's where you
can really uh go deeper with your
community that's where you can start to
communicate with them asking questions I
like that they did do a poll so that's
good uh polls are really good on YouTube
lots of questions happening but if
you're not seeing people answering your
questions we gotta switch up that model
so
um I would be asking or I would maybe be
posting different things um that people
could vote on uh to make sure that
you're getting more of that content from
your audience to be able to help you
with that but really good uh Channel I
think the channel is heading in the
right direction
um few tweaks could lead to Giant Peaks
I would say also Rob on that um the top
Banner
did you address that that those words
are really kind of hard to read over
that one yeah there can be yeah that
could be fixed by maybe adding a stroke
effect of a font yeah making a font
thicker and easy to read so yeah
um
it's very basic fun yeah and it feels
very redundant too it's like reluctant
diy-ers reluctant diyers and then also
in the in the um in the Avatar so that
even could be switched up too just to
maybe add for more branding
um obviously it's the name of all the
things which makes sense but um I would
just be thinking about The Branding
overall so really good
that's exciting well hey Rob uh we're
doing something brand new with bit IQ
which I'm really excited about
um we have an opportunity for people to
get the Boost plan for one dollar can
you tell us a dollar goodness tell us a
little about what they're gonna get Rob
uh when they uh take advantage of this
one dollar boost planned offer yeah so
I'm sure many of you uh are familiar
with vid IQ and we have a lot of free
tools which are absolutely fantastic
they will open up the the hood of the
YouTube video so to speak and give you a
bit of analysis but what boost does is
start to offer you more decision making
tools uh if you can share my screen
however I can just demonstrate very
quickly um Donna left-hand side we have
all of these tools including keyword
inspector Trend alerts competitors but
we're now transitioning more into
um the AI side of things so that we can
help tap into the human element of why
somebody clicks and so just as an
example I'm going to throw up our daily
ideas for the um
vid IQ Channel and I haven't seen these
today but we have 50 daily ideas and
I've got it into list form so you get
this every single day on Boost you get
all of these video ideas and of course
for your channel it's not going to
suggest YouTube education ideas it
tailors itself to whatever type of
content you're making so for Chris Alex
it would be probably Halloween ideas for
reluctant DIYs it might be more ideas
behind drywall because I know you use
that a lot in your titles for us it's
ideas such as seven big mistakes small
YouTubers still make funnily enough I
made that video last year and it got 1.2
million views so is it time to do
another one possibly or I solved
YouTube's biggest problem what an
incurious and intriguing title that is
imagine if I could tie that into
a thumbnail which had me pointing at a
YouTube metric which was maybe blurred
out or a YouTube metric YouTube feature
that was blurred out I'm already getting
ideas in my head just from that
suggestion and so many of these are
going to be suited to my channel and
your Channel
uh when uh you uh take advantage of this
offer that's just daily ideas if you
wanted to do a bit more traditional
keyword research then in our web app
let's say you're into real estate as a
channel I'm just going to type in
and one of my favorite new tools here is
our
question conversion tool I'm going to
call it today it's going to take that
keyword and then it which is real estate
and then turn it into effectively 300
different search ideas how to become a
real estate agent how to make money in
real estate how to get into real estate
with no money that's intriguing in
itself you can do that with no money all
right I'm up for that how to wholesale
real estate step by step how to make
videos to get real estate leads that's
really interesting as a topic and I
could scroll endlessly here if I was
into real estate and come up with 25 to
50 ideas all about the topic of real
estate and that is through generating
questions through our keyword research
so what I've done there Heather is just
showing you the literal tip of the vid
IQ Iceberg that's two of our tools of
the dozens that we have but I don't want
to
um throw everything onto you it's like
invest that single dollar and then see
what it unlocks vid IQ because the
opportunities are tremendous with all of
these tools that we have
so so exciting so you can uh go to
vidiq.com forward slash think and you
can get started on that one dollar trial
if you love vid IQ let us know in the
comment section
um it's definitely one of my most
favorite tools that I use on the
platform anyone that I'm telling should
come to the platform I'm telling them
they definitely should get uh vid IQ and
I love this vid IQ there we go lit this
is really good I was trying to find it
Rob I was like scrolling trying to
figure out where it was so
um love that so much and you can
definitely go to
thinkmedia.com forward slash so no go
back vidiq.com forward slash think
that's how you can get over to that and
uh clinch Fitness says I use vid IQ
every day gotvid IQ thanks to VRA thanks
Mark for uh being a part of both of our
worlds
um everything Aja says I have it so
really exciting about that
um Chris loves vid Q as well so there
you go if you're a content creator and
you've not yet downloaded vidiq gotten
your free or gotten your one dollar
trial make sure you get that so you can
um level up your content all right Rob
why don't you do yours I'll do mine and
we'll see how many more we can get in in
the top of the hour sure you've got
family Tech yeah I'm gonna be interested
uh in your input on this one however
I've sort of gone through some of the
basics because that what I understand it
to be even though it's taken a bit of
time decoding this in the background is
I think it is a channel based around
making the digital world a safe place
for parents and their families and
the way I've seen this is just by seeing
certain words in some of the thumbnails
like obviously fighting against
pornography the best gadgets for your
kids healthy gaming for your kids and
family but that has taken me like 10 to
15 seconds really looking at these
thumbnails and reading them to get an
idea of that and then what I also think
is
forgive me if I'm wrong Heather but you
as a parent are probably quite a busy
person do you have time such as one hour
to invest in safety tips with your
family I'm sure it's very important but
do you have that time so I'm thinking as
this Creator could you experiment with
taking clips from these maybe live
stream interviews and turning them into
four or five minute segments which
address a very particular topic from
each of these
um longer sessions
um and then I guess my question to to
you Heather as a parent is like what
what are the important things that this
Creator probably needs to address
for the viewer what's going to make them
click beyond what looked to be fairly
complex titles and thumbnails yeah I
think that idea of like Internet safety
right that's like the first word that
came to my mind or protecting your kids
online
um that to me would definitely be where
my brain would go but you were so right
Rob and I saw these were hour long I was
thinking that's a long time to be um
going through a content and there must
be a lot talked about inside of those
sessions that could definitely um be
shortened down I think and and this
looks like to me maybe a long-form
podcast I wasn't I didn't click through
so I'm not sure but I'm thinking it's
probably a long form podcast and when
you do that you want to be just like you
said Rob you want to be taking the
biggest moments and posting those as
shorter
um form Clips but I think this is a
really good topic I would be thinking
what is your total addressable Market
all parents that
um all parents that have their kids
online and I would be thinking things
like uh I was just looking the other day
of YouTube kids so like figuring out
specific platforms that you could be
protecting protecting your kids on how
do you set up certain boundaries and
what are those things like online those
are just some of the things that come to
mind instantly as a parent I mean
success leaves Clues and you can see
that the most viewed videos on here are
certainly shorter I mean they're still
coming in at 20 minutes some of these
but I would say at the moment these
long-form pieces of content are not well
served to your target audience in terms
of how much time they've got to invest
it feels almost and forgive me if I'm
doing a Creator a bit of a disservice
here but they're they're getting this um
these interviews and they're using
YouTube as one of their
asset dumping grounds to just place the
content here
um and not putting in enough effort to
suit the audience's needs I apologies if
I'm
misrepresenting the Creator's intent
here but you know maybe they just don't
have the time to really make this
content valuable for their target
audience and they're just they're just
throwing it onto YouTube Someone
yes I would also say those um thumbnails
are quite busy uh and even just seeing
them from where I am right now it feels
like a lot of overlapped in in what it
is and the idea of even having like the
faces on there they're so small that
it's hard for me to even see what the
emotion is or you know who the two
people are
um so I think there definitely could
just be some level up of the uh
thumbnail design
um to help reach your target audience
you know is it is it kids on a tablet
like that would actually help me see
um more so what that is but it is that a
book is that a you know that's so small
in comparison to what I'm actually uh
learning and this looks like Hank Green
uh because the image is so true I don't
think it is I think it's uh family gamer
TV but it looks very similar my question
here would be
um
in terms of uh healthy gaming for kids
and family what would you say Heather is
the number one priority would be would
it be
um time you're you allow your kids to
play on the device or making sure that
the content is age-appropriate I'm
thinking you grab one of those crucial
elements and sell that a little bit more
rather than this broad topic because I'm
not seeing a big enough why all right
it's healthy gaming for kids and family
but what is the most important thing
here why do I need to know about this
rather than dysfunctional title yeah and
you're hitting it exactly right Rob for
me like the first thing that came up is
um I had to learn how to turn the chat
off of a lot of my kids because I don't
want them to be chatting with anyone
online
um five safe games for kids under five
years old like I would want to know what
are the recommendations
um for those types of things too so I
think you're right success leaves Clues
and you know you see sometimes Rob
creators will do this they'll start to
change the style of content which can be
a good thing but you have to look at the
analytics and say is this working you
have to take a a step back look at your
content and say is this working for the
right results that I'm trying to
accomplish
um and that just is in general as a
content creator I think every quarter
you should evaluate all of the content
that you've created that quarter and
decide is this working for what I want
to accomplish yeah so six months ago uh
four thousand views two and a half
thousand views three and a half thousand
views these all look as if they're
dedicated to camera
um conversations with the viewer as
opposed to these which feel more like
conversations with another Creator and
again does the maybe the view of me
feels a little bit excluded you know
they're just listening into someone
else's conversation rather than being
addressed directly
definitely I love that well Rob I want
to uh share out a star student uh this
is someone who dropped their links here
inside of the chat and just really go
into
um what a great YouTube channel can look
like as you're growing an online
business and that is the simple Heritage
home making
um one thing that I noticed right away
was how light and Airy uh this channel
feels like I feel like you instantly
know exactly what this channel is about
and I love that they've committed to new
video every Tuesday
um I I personally don't like to put what
day I'm gonna post my videos uh but I do
think it's really great if you want to
be holding yourself accountable if you
want to be someone who is going to show
up regularly for your audience on a
specific day
um I think it's really really wise and
guess what I know what she's doing she's
making bread that's what I think is so
cool about what you can do on YouTube
already at 38 000 subscribers and
started at the beginning of 2019. so you
are already at a 1.9 million views as
well on this channel so congratulations
on growing a very steady Channel and can
I just applaud also Rob
all of the content that's in this
description to tell me exactly what
we're making are you trying to make
sourdough starters and bake bread from
scratch yes I am then you're in the
right place right I think the first
three words are crucial it's addressing
the viewer like are you trying to do
something and a lot of the about
sections tend to be about the the
Creator as opposed to what their mission
is for the viewers it's a fantastic
start yes yeah so really great job on
just all of that
um uh pieces I'm gonna shout out this
community tab uh really great job using
imagery beautiful imagery on your
community Tab and really understanding
that those first two lines are what
really matter when it comes to this now
here's the only thing I will caution you
for on this one is that you are using
your community tab as a poster board for
your YouTube videos
so I would just be making sure that
you're also including the community
asking questions using the polls asking
them to vote on things rather than it
just being another place that you're
posting your YouTube videos but really
great job of using this Square image
because look what it's doing it's taking
up the entire screen when I'm on here
and I know exactly what I'm gonna get if
there's one thing I know about this
channel I know exactly what I'm going to
get when it comes to
um creating content now I think what's
really great is uh your most popular
videos are leading directly into what
you want to sell which is amazing
because easy sourdough no feeding no
disc no discards uh is leading directly
into when I click on the blog check this
out this the super simple sourdough
course I want that Rob that's the one I
want to buy I don't want to buy the
complicated one I want to buy the super
simple sourdough course
um so really great job on being able to
lead people exactly where you want to
lead them and it looks like you've been
growing
um this online business uh for a little
while and added YouTube to it so I think
it's really great to see what you're
doing over here on YouTube success
leaves Clues and especially if you're
selling sourdough make sure you're
making sourdough so I see here you did
this again sourdough without just uh
discards look at that guys another 3 000
views on this video that's just a remake
of her best video so just to know that
you can actually remake content over the
years as you are growing your YouTube
channel now I do see that you're
starting to add in a couple extra things
other than just being
um like farmers market in Germany
um and that those to me are fun those
necessarily those won't necessarily
Drive traffic to your to your course or
to your blog but I think it's fun that
you get to actually include you know she
went to Germany and she's talking about
German food which I think is smart that
she's actually on the same track of that
so I think this is a really great
example of a channel that is um very
simple if I look at like how simple even
the videos are after we get through this
ad really quick uh we'll I'll bring you
through the ad I don't know why my head
blockers not working
uh very simple videos she's got a
lavalier microphone making it very easy
looks like there's probably a simple
light that's on her and this looks like
to me Rob like it could be just an
iPhone this doesn't seem like it's a
very
um crazy camera so this looks like very
simple or just a very simple uh phone
that this Creator is using
um and then yes you're doing a great job
of even getting into your comments and
understanding how to use your tags this
is just a great example of a content
creator that if you just keep going
You're Gonna actually see some really
great results so a great job on that one
um there as well
branding was just absolutely on point
absolutely perfect
um the one
the one thing I was going to maybe
question but it kind of felt as if it
was part of a branding as well is that
they did put text on all of their
thumbnails yeah and typically speaking
when it comes to food or Tech
or the the hero of a video is an object
then you wanna
show off that object as much as possible
and I think there was one in particular
I think they were talking about a carrot
cake but I couldn't see the carrot cake
at all I could read the book saying
carrot cake but I couldn't see the
carrot cake itself now there could be a
challenge with removing the text because
then you're kind of taking away a bit of
your branding I would imagine that most
people who love your content your
thumbnails are a very distinctive brand
and consistency so they'll just click on
the thumbnail irrespective of what's
actually on the thumbnail because they
can tell it's from this Creator but I
mean some of the text in the thumbnails
is illegible I can't read it at all and
I think whenever they have like a One
Bowl bit of text and then a smaller bit
of text underneath or above it you could
probably do with not using that because
it probably a waste of space in my
opinion
and it does feel like I mean now going
through and looking at them it's just a
replication of what the title is and you
want to make sure that your title and
your thumbnail
um are actually uh um supportive of each
other so you're doing exactly almost the
exact same things on each of your
thumbnails and your titles uh I like
this fail proof that's cool that's a
good word failed proof
um so just be thinking about how you can
you can make those maybe not as exact
like Oktoberfest in California
Oktoberfest in California so not
necessary to have those two things back
to back on there but this would be
I would think star student of this
review Rob this is a star student of
this review yeah maybe you just need
that word um have a fail proof as
opposed to what was underneath it love
there's one here cultured butter like
you can tell that's butter so do you
need the word culture butter there or
something moral on the lines of
um the best the best taste ever or you
know something that uh pulls out a
feeling and an emotion as opposed to
repeating what's on the on the tin so to
speak
definitely well Rob that wraps up our
views for today thank you so much where
can people find you if they want to
check out more of the reviews that vidiq
does so what you can do right now folks
is if you want you can raid our vid IQ
video reviews so Heather and I have just
been auditing channels but right now and
I'm going to jump over onto there in a
couple of minutes we're doing video
reviews where we actually don't look at
a thumbnails on the titles we press play
and then we say to ourselves was this a
good hook and am I going to watch the
rest of the video so I think that's
going on for another hour so you can
join us there but otherwise if you just
type in vid IQ I'm always looking at
Twitter Instagram the comments if you
see a reply it's generally from me
amazing thank you so much Rob for
joining us today if you would like to
see more Channel reviews just like this
you can click or tap the screen right
now and if you want to see the latest
podcast from the think media team you
can click or tap the screen right now to
watch that podcast thanks so much for
watching we'll catch you in the next
video bye fam